i should tell you something else which  didn't show on the television  yeah foucault you know is totally bold  yeah  yeah the moderator fonts elders  is a very interesting person he was a  dutch anarchist  there was a dutch anarchist movement at  that time which was  doing all sorts of things like uh giving  lsd to horses that fancy  horseshoes so that they'd jump all over  the place making fun of the one  on the way to the studio fonts elder  stopped at his apartment  went upstairs came down he had a bright  red  wig in his hand and through the whole  debate  if you notice closely he was nudging  cuckoo and saying  put it on put it on  that is an incredible detail yeah  that is something else uh well listen uh  professor noam chomsky  i i so appreciate your time today and  the fact that we were able to do this  and to put it together  uh really thank you so much for your  time i so appreciate having you on  thank you